[Musique]
il ya quelques semaines je suis allé à
baltimore pour asml 2022 la première
conférence ultra prestigieuse en à
xining depuis le début du coc vide
c'était l'occasion de rencontrer plein
de gens super sympa à la pointe mondiale
de leurs domaines de recherche
se penche
c'est théo fille doctorants annuelle
d'été ma première conférence et du coup
c'est une très belle expérience pour
l'instant j'ai un peu de cette recherche
le comique on y trouve de la profession
la vie privée notamment l'apprentissage
prix et le second
[Musique]
tout autour de l'éthique et la 306 yens
je travaille sur tradition
j'ai sur la causalité ajouté
de la com - formation des questions de
formation
merci des questions de
modèle économique pour l'écouter
et fabiano sera le des internationaux en
ligne se fait de la recherche sur les
réseaux de neurones et faire en sorte
qu'il soit plus efficace plus rapide
à utiliser et moi avec un nom pas de
plus faible sur l'environnement organise
un séminaire avec le sociologue
publicité et qui s'appelle sévignacq
critique de l'intelligence artificielle
on peut mettre du personnel chez nous
à siemens est un lieu de publication
ultra prestigieux avec sur place des
tutoriels des conférences et des séances
de poster mais entre difficultés à
obtenir un visa pour de nombreux
chercheurs les présentations via zoom et
les réticences du haut que vides
l'événement est paru un peu
surdimensionné avec d'énormes salle des
conférences souvent très vite l'instar
notamment de celle où j'ai présenté
notre article accepter a essayé mais je
vous reparlerai plus en détails de cet
article qui est un peu un des bonnes
king est un article de chercheurs de
google car il est 10 heures
mais s'il y a un truc dont j'aimerais
vous parler dans ce blog c'est du
malaise grandissant que j'ai vis-à-vis
de beaucoup voire de la quasi totalité
des travaux qui sont présentés comme
vous le savez peut-être si vous me
suivez sur twitter l'écrasante majorité
des publications dans le domaine reste
consacré à la performance avec quasiment
systématiquement des hypothèses qui sont
irréalistes dans le cas des algorithmes
et plus puissants d'aujourd'hui et qui
me préoccupe tellement en particulier la
sécurité est quasiment inexistante à tel
point que même des concepts de base de
la sécurité comme les attaques par
empoisonnement ou parc radiant sont
méconnues voire inconnus de beaucoup
d'experts mondiaux en machine orner les
articles et essais d'adressé la sécurité
sont parfois d'une qualité très
discutable ainsi pour l'anecdote quand
j'ai demandé un chercheur en
apprentissage distribués s'il avait
envisagé la possibilité d attaques
adverses arial par des participants au
système distribué typiquement des fermes
de trolls qui veulent courir les données
/ les algorithmes de recommandations
pour déterminer quels contenus amplifier
le chercheur à qui j'ai posé cette
question était complètement perdue m'a
demandé si je parlais de protection des
données personnelles alors que vraiment
pas du tout
de la même manière la distinction entre
attaques adverses arial par évasion et
attaques adverses arial par
empoisonnement et est très floue pour
beaucoup de chercheurs de façon plus
terrifiant encore beaucoup de travaux
étaient si théorique beaucoup trop
optimisée à des dates à celles qui ne
correspondent pas à des cas
d'application pratique que beaucoup de
chercheurs présents à haïti m elle ne se
rendait en fait pas compte des
véritables applications à grande échelle
de leurs travaux pourtant pour le
découvrir il suffisait de jeter un oeil
à la liste des sponsors de l'événement
qui sont aussi ceux qui financent plus
la recherche académique public en
machine on y trouve bien sûr les google
l'état ou autres amazon dont le machine
orné sert clairement surtout à la
recommandation de contenu et à la
publicité ciblée
je suis en fait extrêmement déçu du
manque d'attention donner à ses
algorithmes particulièrement influent
mais qui sont complètement ignorées y
compris dans des tracts comme ia et
changement climatique alors que
clairement et j'y reviendrai bientôt sur
scène ce forum la surconsommation est un
enjeu critique du changement climatique
sur lequel influe énormément les
algorithmes de recommandations et de
publicité ciblées
bref en réécoutant le blog triplé à et
que j'ai fait il ya trois ans et surtout
l'interview chez blank ce que j'ai donné
à ce sujet même si le lait de 2019 était
déjà pessimiste je me dis qu'il était
encore bien trop optimiste
trois ans plus tard malgré le coc vide
les émeutes du capitole et les invasions
de l'ukraine où la crise informationnel
joue clairement un rôle central malgré
aussi le démantèlement de l'éthique chez
google et la révélation de facebook
files le danger mondial d'une mauvaise
priorisation algorithmique de
l'information demeure un sujet qui est
complètement une muse c'est à dire un
sujet complètement ignoré y compris par
la communauté de chercheurs en sciences
de l'information et de son traitement
automatisé
et ça je trouve cela absolument
terrifiant